hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be unboxing and doing a quick
overview of the power shot g5x by canon
and this is kind of the big brother or
the upgraded version of the g7x the
pretty much every youtuber has been
using for the past year and a half maybe
even longer so whatever that camera came
out pretty much everyone switched to
that camera and now this one came out a
few months ago so it's still fairly new
and not too many people are using it yet
but I'm excited to try it out I'm also
filming here as you can see here in this
frame this is the g7 X and that's what
I've been using for pretty much all of
my vlogs there's a lot of similarities
between this one and the g7 X it has the
same sensor same lens and same image
processor so there's not a huge
difference overall as far as like
autofocus and a few other things that I
think could make a huge difference in
some of our vlogs enough yapping let's
open it start from the bottom now we're
here started from the bottom now the
whole camera will be sitting here sorry
from the bottom of the box now the whole
camera is sitting right here alright
let's take a little peek inside this
little bag we've got the new g5 X the
first thing that I'm noticing as I'm
holding it here in my two hands it is
slightly heavier than the g7 X not a
huge difference but it does have a
little bit bulkier of a field you'll
notice right off the g5 X has a hot shoe
it also has a digital viewfinder so when
you look inside of here you actually be
able to see what your camera is seeing
but for a lot of us that's really not
necessary because most of the time
you'll be using the flip out screen
speaking of labelled screens this g7 X
has a flip up screen the g5 X has a flip
out screen like most of the DSLRs that
you guys are pretty familiar with it
also does flip to the front so you'll be
able to do your wonderful front-facing
vlogs but remember when you're vlogging
and please do not look off to the side
and look at yourself in that camera
because you guys it's so obvious and
it's one of my biggest pet peeves of
watching people when they're creating
their videos so right now I'm looking at
the lens right now I'm looking off to
the side at myself do not do that so I
read somewhere online that you are able
to plug in an external mic but I'm not
sure if I believe them or not because I
don't see any options
of where you can do that here you have
your micro USB and your mini HDMI what I
love about a lot of these cameras is
you're able to connect them to Wi-Fi it
is super simple all you have to do is
hit this little tiny button right here
this will allow you to set it up so any
of the photos or videos that you take on
your camera you can connect it to your
phone and you'll be able to instantly
get them onto your phone so a lot of the
photos that I post on Instagram I
actually take them with this little guy
that's why they look so good yes I know
it's cheating I feel like there's more
stuff in the box and I just set it aside
whoa g5x
has a neck strap not sure if has
something on into but it could be could
I be into this I'm not sure oh yes it's
the same battery as the g7x which is
such a huge Savior because I've bought
extra battery chargers and I have extra
batteries so I'll be able to swap
between those and of course when I'm
traveling a lot of youtubers and for
getting batteries or forgetting chargers
so we're able to always share with each
other yes this is great nose okay let's
put you in here I need an SD card okay
let's put this in it's only a naked card
so I'm probably not gonna be able to do
anything on the g7x this is the flash so
they moved this little settings wheel
over to the left where that was because
now this has a pop-up flash here on the
hot shoe also looks like all of these
buttons are still very similar they move
the record button up here slightly but
the menu the review and all of these are
all still pretty identical let's turn it
on I'll set the time ouchies hold on
we've got all of the same settings here
pretty much the real test for me is how
is the video and the audio going to be
I'm sure the photos are absolutely
amazing just like they usually are with
every other Canon camera so that's not
something that I'm concerned about
hoping it around hey guys how are you
this is a little test from the g5 x you
look good what's this do acceptor you're
not doing something
Papa's around whoa hello okay I'll drink
anything in the g7x there has this
little click wheel now when you would
turn this you can use that to adjust
aperture ISO or pretty much whatever you
want to set it to it's really loud on
this one this one the g5x very quiet as
far as the interface goes it looks
pretty much exactly identical to the g7x
one of the things that a lot of vloggers
have been doing with their g7x is
shooting in 60 frames a second so this
also has that option as well and as I'm
looking at it here you probably
obviously can't tell because I'm looking
at it and you can't see it it is pretty
smooth the image stabilization is pretty
incredible cuz I'm shaking this a lot
and it's still stabilizing it pretty
well some of you guys probably don't
even know why the videos look very
smooth so a lot of those videos are shot
in 60 frames a second so it's shot at a
higher frame rate so everything looks
very smooth and kind of put together a
lot of you think that it's a little bit
too fast so you prefer to have the
slower frame rate vlogs so I'm curious
to see what you guys think because
there's always a big dilemma in the
video some people like wow this looks so
real and crisp and the other ones are
like oh my gosh I'm getting so nauseous
I can't even watch this so let me know
in the comments below what you guys
think and let me know what you guys
think of this camera I know this isn't a
completely crazy in-depth tutorial or
review of it so again this is the g7x
which I use for most of my vlogs and
this is the new g5 X which recently came
out and I'll be testing this out and
using it in some of my vlogs here in the
next week you guys want more information
to check out this camera or if you
actually want to get it for yourself
I'll put a link in the description the
only downside to this is it is a little
bit more expensive than most of the
consumer power shot cameras but judging
by the amount that I have used this
camera which was also a little bit more
expensive for me it was well worth the
price and I think that for you guys if
you're planning to take your vlogs or
your video creation to the next level
this is definitely something that you
would want to consider but also at that
price you could get a full DSLR that you
can use interchangeable lenses so really
the option is do you want something
small and portable that you can take on
the go or do you want something that you
can have that you can have more
customizations have
do input and things of that nature so
don't forget to let me know what you
guys think of the 60 frames first the
slower framerate vlogs I'm done
wait because we got the chairs now oh
yeah stop I'm last energy I'm ordering
groceries from the phone this is wild